when I first read the screenplay for
transcendence halfway through the script
I realized I get access to all the porn
the world blonde threesomes gangbangs
cocky Chinese Japanese allocation girls
transcendence I'm wearing my glasses
today because Johnny Depp wears glasses
this movie has like a negative eighty
percent on rotten tomatoes and oh boy I
have a feeling I'm about to get a lot of
[ __ ] for what I'm about to say I really
enjoy the hell out of this movie I
appreciated the hell out of this concept
although there's one hell of a
fascinating time apparently I really
believe in help sure it has some very
apparent flaws like fat people but
overall it's a very interesting science
fiction picture just the concept of
hooking up your consciousness to a
supercomputer I love to hook my
consciousness up to a macbook pro and
then edit all day long you guys get so
many more trailer reactions I found a
way to develop through the reactions and
make them more events than ever the
greatest reaction you'll ever see and
for what I hear they're actually pretty
close to developing this technology so
get ready to get pissed off all you
Christians out there I really don't see
what the problem is everyone has with
this movie it starts off genuinely
intriguing and unlike a lot of Hollywood
movies it actually has some really good
character in it Johnny Depp as well
something or another hook looks Johnny
dead ah he turns in a significantly more
subtle performance he does a great job
at it like the first 30 minutes of this
film he's a human being and I totally
believe him as this guy and when he's a
computer sure he's a little bit robotic
he's a [ __ ] computer what else do you
expect Scarlett Johansson from her damn
dude I would bang that boys and when he
becomes the computer the trailers made
it look like he becomes super bad guy at
that point which is how the characters
do react to him but here's the funny
thing pug was on his side the whole time
I'm like he's healing the [ __ ] world
undo his thing what the [ __ ] is wrong
with everyone in this movie stupid
people I hope this does not happen to
real life when they hook up Johnny Depp
to a computer yeah whatever he's 20
nature humanity but don't we do that all
the [ __ ] time have you ever been in
California and seeing the air is
polluted I get stoned every time I walk
outside it has to be at least one main
character that supports us so I thought
it was kind of a flaw rebecca hall as
depths wife me she's the real star of
this movie she has great character
moments very emotional I love her life
descent into confusion and madness you
know you see it coming i goes this good
is this bad I can't have sex with him so
it's really worth it I felt like she's
the one who carried this whole movie
like when she's sad you feel sad by only
prom with her performance she did not
get me morning did he got a bunch of
other stars in this movie got Morgan
Freeman doing is Morgan Freeman thing
then you got the great character actor
chili and Murphy playing in normal cops
right they got this awesome actor to
play a very normal performance but Paul
Bettany he reprised his role as the
albino in this movie I'm kidding many
people believe me that you're [ __ ]
[ __ ] he's guys to know who he is he
is a significantly less successful actor
in the relationship he has with Jennifer
Connelly oh come on Jeff recology way
miss gets more work but she's way more
famous he it's more and bigger words
like what well I mean we're both ending
he's been in more movies and Wimbledon
between Noah and whatever the last thing
Jennifer Connelly did what was the last
thing did she want an Oscar are you
assuming she's just that he's just not
that into you a beautiful mind regular
little dream I'm gonna go uh she's been
named one of the sexiest people in the
world ones paul bettany been named one
of those lists he's pretty much now he's
not that on yeah and he was in a
beautiful mind too so that one day i was
a beautiful mother he was increased yes
and the taurus anyway yeah Paul Benji's
character arc in this movie it's great
and image I never really know what
box-office smash hits to collide on and
you got one of my favorite actresses on
the first season of American Horror
Story kate mara oh my Venus is thinking
some thoughts right now I would love to
have sex with her sister rooney mara my
only problem is I wouldn't want to say
the name Rooney during sex it just
sounds weird like Oh Rooney
I feel like I'm talking to a guy I
probably call her like Michelle or
something but anyway yeah Kate she does
a great job now the directing from
Waller fly sir he's like the main
cinematographer for like a [ __ ] ton of
Nolan films now with this direction I
thought it was a little interesting
sometimes a little off yes
cinematography looks gorgeous around
absolutely the first 40 minutes of this
film is what I love the most where they
have a lot of their ideas that's where a
lot of the debate of technology goes on
that's where they explore rift a lot the
anti-technology terrorist group and it's
great [ __ ] now this film it's a little
weird and tone because a lot of films
that start off slow and a lot of them
will build and go faster and faster this
film starts off like at a reasonable
pace and gets faster and one tense and
then it slows down quite a lot to
actually they go to like desert world
but I actually liked everything that was
going on with slow down once you
readjust to it see that there's a lot of
great character moments I like all the
[ __ ] that Johnny Depp's character is
building like all the technology to like
he'll humans be you know technological
Jesus Christ it was [ __ ] awesome I
just thought this film goes in
directions that are very imaginative and
the trailer tries to make it look like
this super suspenseful movie it's not
but it's you know it's more of a drama
it actually has a little bit of a poetic
tale about it about technology so yeah I
dug the film Johnny Depp whenever he's
on screen I just [ __ ] love watching
him i want to suck his dick let me get
straight to the point here all in all i
gotta say transcendence got it ryan
right
alright guys he's checking out my review
for transcendence watch go ahead
sterling comment box below and tell me
if you were able to hook yourself up to
a computer what would you do and if you
want see more episodes straight to the
point and I'm not throwing out there
Jerry now I'm gonna be doing a spoiler
review of transcendence so people look
out for that and while you're at it go
check out his first impressions video
where he gives his solo review about
transcendence he's in the car according
themselves yeah I record myself
sometimes too but it's not for rubies
I'm jacking off the last but not least
you can we get updated every time one of
my reviews or videos is out go ahead and
click on this but about my dick to
subscribe that's right the dick let me
tell you something out this little Willy
he's gonna upload some consciousness
tonight